there's a uh handmade t-shirt
that's available on etsy that's getting
some notice
and i just wanted to put a word out for
this t-shirt
i guess do you do you know who made this
t-shirt if some woman
came up with it i believe is that
correct it is it's it's it's a thing
it's a it started
on the internet as a
a a gif yeah and and now it is a
shirt and i i've never seen one in
person yeah right
you should get one we should we should
we should each get one and then we
should you and i should go out for
steaks
uh yes this shirt says how many lows
could rob lowe rob if rob lowe could rob
lowes and um
and there's information you can get this
on etsy and apparently
yeah it's a thing people are getting
these shirts i hope you're getting a
piece of this
well here's my well i was like hmm
how do i get a piece of this so i had my
my managers and agents
call lows and say this is an internet
thing
it's a sensation it's on the internet
it's this kind of cool subversive thing
their
shirts being sold we should do something
with lows and they were like we don't
really see the connection
okay yeah you're lows
uh forget it yeah i think it's the wrong
person
swell of connecting who needs it yeah no
they said no one's really buying things
over the internet so
just relax yeah that's what the people
at lowe's said they were not i think
they didn't get it
well i want to thank you very much for
your time a delight
is always talking to you and
congratulations again literally with rob
lowe which is currently number three
on the charts is available wherever you
consume
because we all consume podcasts we don't
just listen to them we consume them
no we not only to consume them we put a
hat on them and then we had on them yeah
new episodes drop every thursday and
it's really a delight it sounds like
you're having a lot of fun doing it
yeah i gotta tell you it has been i i
thought it might be fun
it's way surpassed uh what i thought it
would be
uh the guests have been insane and just
to talk to ask
the things of people that that you just
people don't get a chance to ask them
has been yeah it's been great and i've
been and i love the response so far